The campus Emergency Operations Group is the group of leaders across the
university that is responsible for
responding to different emergency events.
UCLA is really in every respect a small
city 90,000 folks on campus every day.
The magnitude of potential emergencies
is bigger than most campuses it's a
responsibility to the staff, faculty,
visitors and students of this university
to have a team like this that's ready to
act. In a situation an emergency or
almost any time when the campus is not
operating as it normally operates the
CEOG is responsible for providing
resources to the folks in the field who
are actually handling the emergency. We
activated for the great flood of 2014; For
the shooting incident of 2016. We actually
responded to a recent brush fire that
happened adjacent to campus. It was
great to see how our teams interacted
with each other and how they responded
to that disaster. It's really important
that we get to know each other. We work
together very well during trainings and
exercises so that when we have
significant emergencies that affect the
campus we know each other and we work in sync.
We recruit from all over campus. We
recruit from every discipline. Any staff
or faculty member can join the CEOG. It's really important to have people from all
over campus participating an emergency
response because we all bring really
different skills to the table. Being part
of the housing department, because I'm
part of mass care and shelter, I know a little bit more about sleeping
accommodations and dining arrangements
so I can bring that knowledge to the
table and help us provide a better
emergency response.
Probably the most rewarding is actually getting a chance to be activated in the EOC. Understanding
how big this community is and how many
factors go into an appropriate response
it's an honor to be part of a team that
helps to reduce injuries and property
damage and save lives. If you're
interested in joining the CEOG staff then
check out our website OEM dot UCLA dot edu or
contact any of the Emergency Team Staff.